MARK BENNETT: Welcome.
Good morning.
God, it's a good crowd today.
Thank you for queuing.
Thank you for coming.
For those of you I've
not met, I'm Mark.
There are some familiar
faces in the audience.
It's great to see people again,
back here at Playtime London.
And it's great to see a packed
house with so many of you
here today.
What's into that?
Well, a lot of what you
just saw on the agenda
is about you guys learning,
learning what we've been up to,
learning about what
we're coming up with.
But I just want to
re-echo what Shannon
said there is like, we'd
like you to be telling us
what more you'd
like to see and what
you'd like to see happening.
So you're going to hear
this thing, feedback.
We love feedback in Google.
So we'd love you guys to
take that on board as well
and give us feedback.
That doesn't include you, Rob.
I don't need your
feedback today.
I get enough of
that all the time.
But it's also, we like to
think you'll have a bit of fun
with your peers,
with your colleagues,
intermingle, spend some
time and get together,
and with, obviously, your
Google business partners.
And what I've been
asked to do, apart
from act as a little
bit of a warm-up act
before the main event starts--
Ellie follows after the break.
That's when you get all the
juicy details of Android,
and of Material Design,
and Studio, Firebase--
is really to talk a
little bit about what's
next for Google Play,
and what we're doing,
and the things
that we think will
happen that will
touch your world
and change some of the
things you're building
over the next few years.
So let's start with you
guys, our developers.
It's your magic,
it's your innovation,
it's your creativity that
brings these supercomputers--
a few fingers pointing-- maybe
we've got a couple of your apps
up on the screen-- but brings
these computers in our pockets
to life.
And as Shannon said,
from UK to Estonia,
it's great to have
so many people here,
from "Age of Lords"--
Alex is staring me out--
to "The Economist," to British
Airways, to "Candy Crush"--
such a diverse collection of
apps and games developers here.
And like he said, the real
future of what play is
is what you guys build and
what you guys demand from us.
So we'd love to hear more about
your imagination, your stories,
and your ideas, and
how your apps are
impacting millions of people.
And the team thought
it would be kind of fun
for me to give a
snapshot of my life
and how apps affect my life.
So I'd start with
my kids, seeing
as my biggest
challenge in my house
is getting my 10-year-old boy
and my 8-year-old daughter
off tablets and smartphones.
They seem to be getting more
and more addicted to them.
So I don't know whether I'm a
great parent or a bad parent.
I'll let you guess-- I
asked both of my kids
to pick their favorite apps.
Obviously, my son is a
big fan of everything
that comes out of our
friends at Supercell,
whether it's "Boom Beach,"
"Clash Royale," his latest.
And he still spends
a huge amount of time
with "Clash of Clans."
My daughter's really got
into "Color Switch," which--
those of you who've
played it-- is right up
there with one of the--
obviously, it drives me crazy.
But her and her friends
absolutely adore this game.
But I could have
listed "Crossy Road,"
"Agar.io." "Subway
Surfer" is another big one
in our household.
And the other thing
that they seem
to spend a huge amount of
time is video consumption.
Those of you who are
into "Minecraft," my son
doesn't really play "Minecraft"
on the XBox anymore.
I just have the
echoes of Stampy going
around my house in his
high-pitched squeal of a voice.
But they're on iPlayer.
Now DisneyLife is out
there, and obviously,
Sky Go for a
football-mad family.
And they really do
dominate our life.
And I think, as
many of you know,
kids are probably the biggest
users of a lot of products
and a lot of games that
are on these devices.
But also, apps and
utilities-- this
is an example that, actually,
my wife and I have started
using Houzz an awful lot.
It's a fantastic app.
We're about to start doing some
renovation work on our house,
and we're a big fan
of this utility app.
It really helps you find
an image of an idea,
share it, and pin
it into a scrapbook.
And it's just a number
of apps that really
change the way you think.
Some of the great stuff in
here is, now, they start
tagging items in the images.
So you can actually,
obviously, go on and look at,
what is that sofa,
what is that lamp.
And it leads you through to
the e-commerce site to buy it.
And a feature I've not
actually used on this
as yet is an augmented reality
feature where you can literally
pick that sofa up and drop
it in situ to find out
if it's going to really look
great in your future lounge.
But there's 100
different apps that
are changing the way
people act and how people
behave when using their phones.
I personally can't
imagine ever printing
a boarding pass again or, in a
major city, phoning for a taxi
when I've got Lyft,
or GetTaxi, or Uber.
And the great thing is that
millions of Android users
have not discovered
how much these apps can
change their lives.
So there's so much more
growth ahead of us.
This was supposed
to be kind of fun.
I realize, seeing this on
the big screen in rehearsal
this morning, it's
kind of scary.
This is me taking a
picture, clowning around
on an app called Masquerade.
I'm sure a lot of you
guys have used this.
This has been a great
example in my house,
just bringing fun, bringing
the magic back into apps.
If you've not
done-- has everyone
done the face swapping?
Yeah, some people haven't.
Do it.
It's really fun.
And so, at a dinner party,
do the face swapping.
And you just see
the magic in people,
especially if they're not
that familiar with what
you can do on a phone.
And it's just hilarious.
Obviously, video it,
post it on social media,
and scare the hell
out of everybody.
But these kind of
experiences just
bring so much fun
into what we do
and what we put
in people's lives.
Yeah, sorry about the scary
clowning around picture.
And these guys,
these guys probably
need a mention, because it
seems to be in everyone's lips
at the moment.
The great thing about what
Niantic and what they've
done with "Pokemon GO,"
for me, it's obviously
brought a lot of
people into gaming.
It's brought a huge amount
of people purchasing
for the first time
in Play, which
is obviously fantastic for all
of us to add new paying users.
But the big thing, I think,
is that two potential impacts
of these game is, it's really
brought augmented reality
into the mass market.
It's taken it out of hyperbole.
And this is no disrespect to
the hundreds of apps developers
that have been working
really hard on AR,
but it's now made this
a mass market thing
around a format of, obviously,
spending time walking around.
But the other thing that I
think is really interesting
about this is it's
hopefully going
to wake up more triple-A
developers, more of that IP
that's been previously just
locked in console and PC,
to a lot of your guys' benefit,
but bring these guys more
into mobile.
And we've seen that with
Nintendo, Square-Enix and EA.
They have been early
adopters of mobile.
But a lot of those big IP
and triple-A developers
have actually not done as
much in terms of bringing
their content onto mobile.
Hopefully, we'll see
a lot more of that
on the back of the
success of "Pokemon GO."
But that's just my story.
That's just a small
slice of my story.
As you guys know, the
beauty of what you do
is that there's apps
and games for everyone.
There's over a staggering 1
million apps on the Play Store
now.
So it's really huge in terms
of the breadth and the depth.
And the message, just
to finish this bit,
is that it's what you guys do.
That's what drives us.
And we love the passion that you
have, the creativity you have,
and the imagination
that drives us on.
And very much, what's
next for Google Play
is what you guys
imagine and create.
So let's cover a little bit of
what we do to help you guys.
Some of you guys know this well.
If you don't know
this, our mission
is really to help you
guys succeed and grow
global businesses.
Every Googler that's here
today with a blue tag
on is here to help you.
I'm not going to stress
the feedback thing again,
but they want to make
your business bigger.
And you're going to hear a lot
on both the apps and the games
sections today about how you
can be more successful on Play.
The biggest thing is,
the platform that we've
created, Play,
and Android is now
the largest app distribution
platform in the world.
And I'll talk, in
the next few slides,
around some of the numbers
that make up Android and Play
and why we're so proud of the
success and scale that we have.
And second one is,
we provide tools
to improve your
performance, whether it's
through deeper analytics, A/B
testing, beta release programs.
You're going to hear a
lot more about this today
from the speakers in
the following sessions,
in the breakout sessions.
And as Eddie's going to talk
about, the new features you're
going to see in Android
N, in Android Studio,
in Firebase, and in Material
Design, there's a lot of stuff
here for you to pick up today.
So try and soak up
as much as you can.
And yeah, try and
stay off the Wi-Fi.
Try not to get distracted.
And try and learn.
And give us feedback
on what you say.
And finally, as a partner, a
lot of what we do-- and you'll
see sessions today-- is
about supporting verticals,
supporting groups of
you as our developers.
Whether it's publishing, whether
it's indie games, whether it's
the media sector,
whether it's families--
and Shazia's got a session
later on today, again,
on families-- is helping these
categories succeed within Play
and creating quite unique
experiences to bring
the best out of the content
you have in those categories.
And that partnership,
again, is critical.
We want that feedback.
Tell us what more things
we could be doing.
Whether it is a reaction to a
first impression of something
you've seen today or a deep bug
bear that's been ticking away
in your engineering team for a
long while, please come to us.
Tell us what you think.
And help us be a
better partner for you.
So let's talk
about distribution.
The good news is
Android continues
to grow at a staggering
rate-- the biggest smartphone
platform in the world, with
over 1.4 billion monthly users.
And that's growing every
week as more and more people
get connected and get a
smartphone for the first time.
As that technology gets cheaper,
as it gets more accessible,
we're going to see more
and more people come.
I was reading the
Horowitz blog yesterday.
And they said that by 2020, 80%
of the world's adult population
will have an
internet-connected smartphone.
Now, forecasts are forecasts,
but the basic trend in momentum
is that the majority of
this planet's population
are going to have
access to the internet
and going to have access to very
cheap, affordable computing.
And the great news for us is the
vast proportion of those users
are going to be on Android.
So that 1.5 million a
day new Android devices
is only going to
accelerate and only
going to give you a bigger
audience to build and take
your products to.
And also, the ecosystem
is getting bigger.
We're not going to talk
a lot about the expansion
of the ecosystem today.
But we have a fantastic
team working hard
to add more OEMs
into that ecosystem
and to bring more
carriers on board.
And we now have over 500
carriers working with Android
and working with Play, and 400
OEMs developing for Android.
And as this ecosystem expands,
it's great news for Play.
The result is,
more Android users
are coming into the Play Store.
They're finding apps.
They're downloading apps.
And more and more of
them are spending.
We now have over a
billion monthly users
who have downloaded a
staggering 65 billion apps just
in last year alone.
So the engagement is huge.
And our work really
has gone into enabling
more of these customers to
actually spend money on Play.
We do a lot of work adding
local forms of payment,
finding ways for
consumers, particularly
in emerging markets, to
make that first purchase,
to educate them on why they
can actually have a better
experience if they spend,
but also to give them access
to local forms of payment.
One of those most
important forms of payments
is what we call DCB.
That's Direct Carrier Billing.
So that's paying through
your mobile phone bill.
And in emerging markets where
gift card penetration is lower
and credit cards not really
relevant for a lot of people,
DCB is incredibly important.
And we now have 100 deals
live in over 41 markets.
And actually, our
hundredth deal was a point
of quite good contention within
our business development teams.
The APAC team was saying it was
a carrier called Idea in India.
The EMIR team were claiming
that the hundredth deal
signed was Vodafone, in EMIR.
Hey, they're great
challenges to have.
Actually, Vodafone went
live first, as a deal.
But I think they're
two great examples.
Idea is one of the
biggest carriers in India,
over 190 million subscribers,
a significant proportion
on Android, and
obviously growing
as more and more of those
customers adopt smartphones.
And Voda, we're
all familiar with,
is the biggest carrier in EMIR.
And that actually
means we've got
100% coverage in most of our
markets in EMIR now on DCB.
So great to have both
those deals now on board
and have such a strong payment
platform with our carrier
partners.
And the good news
is that this is now
starting to actually see a
meaningful effect, particularly
in those emerging markets.
Now, we'd expect these growth
rates to be huge, because we're
starting from a low base.
But we're seeing downloads,
absolute downloads,
four times the level we're
seeing in mature markets.
The consumption is huge,
driven by an expanding platform
as more and more
people get smartphones.
But it's also demand.
People want to be
entertained on these devices.
It opens up a whole
world that they've not
been able to experience before.
And as I talked about in
payments, on the back of that,
our job is to actually enable
more of these people to spend.
And we're seeing a very
fast twice the pace
of spend growth in
emerging markets
than we're seeing
in mature markets
as users make
their first payment
and then become habitual users
in terms of spending what
disposable income they
have on your products.
It's very exciting.
So doing all this, we're
doing some work globally
to expand the platform.
And we're working hard
to help you guys find
your audience in Play.
And then, we hear
this a lot-- we've
don't work around beta
testing and allowing you to do
staged, managed rollouts.
But we got great
feedback from you,
not just at Playtime, but
through the year, about what we
can do to make it easier for
you to recruit beta testers.
Often, you guys--
they're friends.
They're family.
There were people
using that before.
But finding complete newbies
that could act as a great beta
tester has proved to be hard.
So we launched a collection
called the Early Access program
just over a month ago, just
after I/O, with 29 apps
to start off with.
And we've had over a
million installs since I/O.
And what we did, we basically
opened up this collection
to those users that had a
very high propensity to engage
with apps and games early on.
So they were just inquisitive.
They liked to try things.
And we felt this was a
really great audience
to open up to developers.
And the great news is that
we're expanding the program
outside of the
startups and the indies
we had to all developers.
So if you want to
learn more about this--
and you want to learn
more about this-- please
come to the launch smart
session today, or talk
to your BD manager today.
And they can give
you more information
how you can get into this
Early Access program.
And another thing I
just wanted to highlight
is how you drive acquisition.
And for those of you who
have a user acquisition
budget, a marketing
budget, app discovery
is a critical role in
driving your growth,
in driving your user base.
But we wanted to leverage
our experience in ads as well
within the store.
And search ads in Play
launched over a year ago.
And we're seeing
significant success
with search ads in Play.
And the developers that I
see spending on this channel,
I consistently get feedback
there's great CPIs.
This is a really
efficient channel.
And they were using it as part
of their marketing budget,
to find both high-quality
users and users with intent.
And search is a really critical
part of that discovery process
within the store.
You can do search
in a couple of ways.
You can buy a search campaign
that runs across .com
and search within Play.
You can't buy a campaign
just on Play search.
But you can also purchase within
the universal app campaign,
which drives acquisition across
YouTube, across Google search
in Google.com, and other
Google properties as well,
including AdMob-- so,
advertising within other apps.
Universal app
campaigns alone have
driven 3 billion app installs.
So I implore you guys to
try it, and to explore it,
and to give it a go.
We're investing heavily in
helping you acquire more users.
And so you'll see some more
announcements over the coming
months about changes
we're doing in this.
And if you'd like to learn more
about universal app campaigns,
there's a session after lunch.
So please try and
join that as well.
So to summarize the first
bit, this is my asks.
This is it.
This is as bad as it gets.
You can take a picture
of these slides.
These are the basics.
These are things that we want
to see all you guys doing.
They're pretty straightforward.
We continue to repeat
the focus on quality.
My ask for you there
is, quality is king.
We create a lot of tools
to try and allow you
to get your product
better and better.
Please listen to our feedback.
We apply a lot of
resource in our teams
to try and give you that
consulting, that feedback
of how you can
improve your products.
So focus on design.
Make it easy to use.
Really invest in quality.
If the product's not
right, work on it
until you've got that right.
And the iteration
piece follows really
fast on the heels of this.
We've created many
tools to help to do
experiments that lead to direct
performance improvements.
And we've been speaking
to top developers
about how many that use A/B
testing, or staged rollout,
or store listing experiments.
And 70% of top developers say
they use this functionality,
and it absolutely helps them
get their product better.
60% of top developers
use beta testing.
My question is, why are
the rest not doing this.
If this functionality is
really going to help you
guys have better product,
there's no coding,
it's free, it's easy to use,
why aren't all your teams using
these tools that we build?
Please take a chance to learn
more about the tools today.
Again, there's a session,
the launch smart session,
about how you can use our tools
to iterate and get that product
right before you spend precious
user acquisition budget
and find that there's a
retention issue that you
had not spotted before.
Try search ads.
I've just talked about
it on the previous slide.
But next time you sit down with
your user acquisition team,
go through and
ask whether you've
spent any money on search
within Play or universal app
campaigns, and see what the
performance numbers look like.
Developer Console-- we'll talk
about that later on today.
It's a great tool, not just
for your engineering teams,
but also for your marketeers
and the non-engineering folk
within your teams.
It's a great way for you to find
what's going on with your user
base, the analytics about
what your conversion
funnel's looking like.
So again, try and use that.
And also, we have
our Playbook app
with a host of articles
and information in there.
Please try it.
And I think I've mentioned
the feedback one at the end
as well.
OK, that's the asks over.
As the temperature
rises, Latitia
loves to find a venue
with glass ceilings.
I think Playtime has to be in a
warehouse or garage with glass
ceilings in London.
So apologies to
those guys over there
that are really under the cosh.
And it's like I/O, isn't it?
I/O was outdoors and very hot.
And we like to replicate
that here in Playtime.
The last section I
want to talk about
is briefly about the future
and about the future of mobile.
And you've seen
this picture before.
You've probably seen this
like 20 times just on the way
here today.
Face down, touch and
swipe-- great products,
but designed for that
form of interaction.
People download apps from
top charts or search.
And we've built an
entire ecosystem,
a very successful ecosystem
about this type of user
behavior and about this type of
interaction within our store.
But we really think
that mobile is evolving.
And we think it's evolving
in a number of different ways
that will be a new era for
mobile beyond this kind
of mobile first and
touch and swipe era.
And I wanted to talk about
three areas, beyond the click,
beyond the install, and
also, beyond the phone,
and just talk about
some of the investments
Google are making in these areas
that we think will massively
change your perspective
on what you can
do within your products
in the near future
and in the mid-term
future as well.
So beyond the click-- the phone,
starting with the touch screen,
you can tap, swipe--
revolutionary.
Everyone was like, oh god,
this changes the whole way
I'm using a mobile phone.
It will never be the same.
This is the future.
I can't believe I couldn't
actually touch and interact
on a device.
It makes things so much better.
But newer elements of input are
now becoming very, very strong
and will soon be mass market.
Voice is the first one
we wanted to highlight.
A staggering 40% of Android--
Google Android-- app
searches and now using voice.
And that's driven
by huge advances
in natural language
processing that
is helping us understand
the spoken word far
better than we've ever done
before, to a much higher,
higher degree.
And Google's actually
training its models
to ignore background
noise, so it's even easier
to hear what the individual
is saying to the phone.
And so I still amaze people
when I do an "OK Google"
with friends and family.
I still see, how--
what-- what's going on?
I generally think, a bit like
with autonomous cars, in 10,
15 years-- or maybe five years
at the rate of speed autonomous
driving is going--
people look back and say,
what, you really drive a car.
But didn't millions
of people die?
Yeah, again, driverless cars
are much better than-- yeah.
And I think, voice, people
will look back and say, well,
why were you typing.
And why weren't you just
speaking to your computers
all the time?
And devices like Google Home,
which was announced at I/O--
and there's a few other home
speakers that you can interact
with a voice-- are
really going to make
that level of interaction
in the mainstream.
So I think we'll
look back and see,
typing is a thing of
the past, and voice
is one of the main inputs
for a lot of the app
experiences you're building.
Gesture is another huge
area that's coming.
One of my favorite projects,
if you saw it at I/O,
it's a project called
Project SOLI-- S-O-L-I--
that was announced from
Google's ATAP team.
That's the Advanced
Technologies And Platforms team.
This is really cool.
This is just a GIF just
showing the gesture control.
But have a look at the video
from I/O. What it basically
uses is shortwave
radio frequencies,
kind of like radar, to actually
have a detailed understanding
of how your hand is moving.
And then you can start
to actually make changes
in swiping and interact
with your device.
And it's already
very sophisticated
even though it's in a very
early stage of the product.
It kind of reminds me
of "Minority Report."
No?
No one gets that.
I'm showing my age,
yeah-- or maybe
Tony Stark from "Iron Man,"
for those younger devs
here that don't know what
"Minority Report" is--
but yeah, that proper
interaction and a completely
new way of interacting with
an app, or even with a game.
And it won't replace.
I think this will
complement voice.
It will complement touch.
But that third dimension
of gesture control
will bring a new
experience to products.
I think the solid dev kit
for hardware manufacturers
doesn't go live till next year.
So this one really
is a year or two out.
But you can start to think of
great things and applications
you could do around this.
Personally, I just want
to get this one in there.
I'd love to see an app
where I could just play
the piano on top of my phone.
So if someone could
pick that one up-- or,
does anyone have the
Hungry Hippos game?
So I could just bash it.
No?
OK, I'll leave the
creativity up to you guys.
But there's a great
world of ideas
that we could actually bring
out there with this gesture
control, in the app.
Another one is
conversational UI.
If you followed
I/O, you would have
seen the announcement
of Allo, which
has not been in release yet.
But this is bringing bots
into Google's new messaging
platform.
And Allo combines AI
with search assistance.
And the interesting
thing for you guys
is how we bring developers, and
particularly app developers,
into this experience.
And this is a huge area for
Google-- again, [INAUDIBLE]
for everyone,
assistant, bringing AI
into more and more
of our products.
And a big theme for
Play in our team
was how we can bring you
into these experiences
and maybe even bring AI into
your businesses as well.
So voice, gesture,
conversational UI, these
are just three
ways that we think
that the interface of how people
interact with your products
is going to change over
the next few years.
And now let's look beyond
the app and beyond the
install as well.
A lot of you have built
brilliant, brilliant native
experiences, brilliant
experiences to mobile.
But one thing I
think we all agree on
is, it would be great to bring
new users to your products even
quicker.
And still, there
are some hurdles
for that install
experience, some speed bumps
and some access issues
that actually just
don't exist on the
web, particularly
for people in the first time.
And the product team in
Play were just thinking,
wouldn't it be
great if you could
have that same beautiful
experience on the web,
just tap, and then you're there.
And then, a few of the
guys are here today,
and started imagining
how we could actually
bring this to life.
And I'm sure many of you
saw this announcement
at I/O. I'm hoping you have.
I'm assuming you have.
I'm certainly not
going to try and do
what Ellie Powers and the team
did so well on stage at I/O
and talk through this product.
But for those of you that aren't
familiar with Instant Apps,
please spend a bit
of time on this.
What it is is
effectively exactly what
it says on the tin.
You can run an Android
app instantaneously, which
makes it much easier
for users to discover,
to share, and enjoy
your products.
This example here
was an example using
B&H, which is a massive
camera retailer in the States
who have a great app.
But the example is very
pertinent, because obviously,
a lot of people don't really
search for "camera" week
in, week out.
So a lot of people might
not have the B&H app
installed on their phone.
But as you can see
here, someone has gone
through a search experience.
They've clicked on that search.
And what it's done
is it's just gone
straight into the
page within the app
that the user's interest in.
This app is not
pre-installed on the device.
And then, actually, within
that instant experience,
they can then add that product,
if they want, to the basket,
pay with Android
Pay, and check out
without entering any
additional information.
And a lot of people we speak to
think this kind of experience
is incredibly cool.
No visit to the Play
Store, no accepting
permissions, no
waiting for a download,
no having to type in,
again, the same search
results for that camera
within that app--
you're straight there.
You're able to purchase.
It's a fantastic experience.
And really, what it
means, it's a much faster,
it's a much more
seamless experience.
And getting that deep link
right into the right page
of the app-- what
the team have done
is they've broken the apps
into separate modules,
so making it a lot lighter
for those modules actually
to be consumed and
installed on the product.
And then, that instant
flow of the app
is optimized for the device.
And there's a lot of
work going to make
this backwards compatible, a
long way backwards compatible,
to reduce that
friction and allow
Instant Apps on a lot of
previous versions of Android.
And another element
to this-- and this
is, again, another
demo that I've done.
We've just lifted out of
I/O-- is really around--
and it's around a
Buzzfeed video-- is
about how to make
content that exists
in your app really accessible.
Again, the web is very easy.
I can share a link.
Someone's on the web page.
It's great.
But often, that's very
hard to do within the app.
That changes with Instant Apps.
Because as you can
see here, someone's
shared a link to a
cooking video on Buzzfeed
on SMS with a tab that opens
instantly within the Buzzfeed
app, which, remember, is not
pre-installed on the user's
device.
And then they can
access that content.
So this opens up a whole new set
of opportunities for you guys
to really compete with a web
presence-- you don't need
to have a web presence-- try
new marketing techniques,
and try new ways to get
people and customers to engage
with your products.
And then, if people want to
keep the app on their device,
you can.
You can prompt them
into the store,
and they can keep it fixed in.
And this is a real
world example.
I don't have Ficus here to
present with a pay meter
like they had at I/O. But this
is a real world example that
has bugged me multiple times.
You turn up at a car park.
I think the last
time I did, it was
a snow dome in Milton Keynes.
Kids desperate to get in there.
And then I've got a choice--
phone a premium rate number
or download an app.
And clearly, it's a
horrendous experience.
If you could just
literally rock up
to that sign in the car
park, tap on the meter,
NFC could instantly launch an
Instant App on your device.
You could instantly pay.
It's really seamless.
It's really easy.
It's really simple.
It's just cool.
And and I think this is a
real world problem-- well,
you know, first world real
world problem-- but a real world
problem for a few of us anyhow.
I'm sure a lot of you
are excited about it.
A few of our product leads
are here, Michael Solinsky,
Jonathan Carmel.
Don't know where they are.
They're hiding in
the back over there.
There's a hand up there.
If you guys don't
know-- just aggressively
pursue them around
the event today.
They've got a lot of
meetings booked in.
But if you can't
get ahold of them,
speak to your
Android BD manager.
They will make sure that you
get connected about this.
We are in a very small
early access program.
The momentum on this
project is huge.
They're moving at a
really great pace.
So please learn more about it.
It could be a
really huge paradigm
shift in terms of the
app consumption model
and crucially really help you
reduce that friction of how
people consume your app.
Right.
And then finally, beyond
the phone-- how am I doing?
I've got five minutes.
That's great, because it's all
about virtual reality next,
so I can make that one up.
The ecosystem is expanding
from wearables, to car, to TV.
There's still a huge
amount of investment
going into taking that Android
ecosystem to more devices.
For those of you that
are building experiences
that are consumed on
different form factors,
there's a lot more coming.
I talked about that
ecosystem of 400 OEMs working
on Android, which is getting
bigger and bigger all the time.
We also wanted to
announce-- you might
have seen this at
I/O, Play Store
also, on Chromebooks--
Chromebooks have
been hugely successful,
particularly in North America.
IDC just announced that,
in 2016, for Q2 2016,
Chromebook's the number one
spot in the US, outselling Macs.
And the great news is,
now, the Play Store
is available on these devices.
So you'll be able to
offer your Android
apps to millions of
users on Chromebooks
as well without any
additional work,
without sacrificing
any performance.
So it's a kind of
nice one, isn't it?
The world has changed.
We've already done
web to mobile.
Now we're going mobile straight
back to laptops, the other way
around.
So we think that's
fantastic, and again,
opens up exposure for you.
And then finally, I just want to
touch on VR, because everyone's
talking about it.
And clearly, it's a
big part of our future,
and our future on mobile.
Like AR, it's now getting to be
truly immersive, comfortable,
and affordable experience.
This is about the future.
Unfortunately, we don't
have anything on AR
to show you today.
There's no Daydream demo in the
breakout session, I'm afraid.
I have personally done
it quite a few times.
It is awesome.
It's not going to make you
feel any better, because you
haven't played-- unless you've
played around with Daydream.
But it was announced at
I/O, built on the Android M
platform.
We're currently working
with our first partners
to prepare this for launch.
And we do intend to make
this available for you
guys as soon as possible.
Our goal with VR
and with Daydream
is to make it as accessible
to as many people as possible.
And in many respects,
it builds on the work
that we've done
around Cardboard.
Cardboard, I think, has brought
VR to over 5 million people.
And we've had over 50 million
installs of Cardboard out.
So that's a great start.
And that's a great foundation to
build on for the Daydream team.
But what they've done
is they've gone on
to a whole new level of
bringing the software together
with the hardware to create
a premium VR experience.
And that means
working very closely
with a whole host of
Android manufacturers,
with hardware manufacturers
around upcoming phones,
and sharing designs for
the VR viewer product,
and also the
controller that makes
it such an immersive
and exciting experience.
But that's not going to
work without your apps.
This is just a screen grab
of what the Play Store will
look like in virtual reality.
We're creating this
welcoming space
where people can
hang out and explore.
The top row is something
called discovery windows,
where you will be able to
promote your best content.
And users can preview
the experience in VR.
And next, I'd like
to just show you
a very quick video
of how developers
will be able to use the
controller, which is actually
incredible for this as well.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ETHEREAL SOUND EFFECT]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SWOOSHING SOUNDS]
[SWOOSH]
[BOOM, BOOM, BOOM]
[SPARKLING SOUND]
[CASTING FISHING LINE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
It's that controller
that, personally, I
think a lot of people are
incredibly excited about.
The potential-- you can turn
it to a tennis racket, a whisk.
You saw the pancake.
I've done the pancake flipping.
I'm really good at it,
actually, as it happens.
But you can just play
around it, move around it
in lots of different ways.
Rob was laughing at that gag.
We got the same
terrible sense of humor.
But when you start
to see this thing,
your mind is going to be
opened to a whole load
of opportunities
you can do around VR
and around your game
play that will literally
transform the
experience for users
of your products and your IP.
And it's not just
about game developers.
We have a lot of content
owners here today.
One of the best
experiences I've seen
is I've watched a 3D movie in
a 3D cinema on the VR headset.
Immediately, I'm thinking
that anyone on a plane
is going to have
one of these things
on, because it's so much better.
You literally feel like
you're watching something
at IMAX Experience.
And it's incredible for such
a-- putting your headset on,
having that experience, and
turning around and seeing
people next to you, or having
the cinema on your own,
is really cool.
And companies like Wall Street
Journal, HBO, Netflix, NBA
have all committed to
adding VR to the platform.
So content is really
important when
you're bring a new
technology to market.
So that's it.
That's it.
That's the future Google Play.
I'm out of time.
I'm cutting.
I'm going.
Do you want to carry
on a little bit longer?
No?
I'm going to really annoy you.
I talked about feedback.
I talked about having
fun, getting in the ring.
Seeing as it's such
a cool day today
and the temperature
is not too high,
we've got some really thick
sumo outfits that you can go
and put on, just to raise your
temperature a little bit more.
I'd suggest you
challenge your BD manager
to a sumo fight this
afternoon, maybe
after a couple of
mojitos or something.
Lily's going to challenge
me to a fight in a second.
There's a feedback
form you have.
If you fill in that form,
you can get stamps for it,
doing the activities today.
You will get a little surprise.
Just to manage expectations,
it's a little surprise.
It's not a VR headset, or a
car, or anything like that.
Maybe there's a prize there.
I don't know.
But yeah, please fill in.
Please enjoy the day.
It's great to have
so many of you here.
It's great to get Playtime back.
It's great that the team
has done such an amazing job
with the venue again.
So please enjoy it.
I'd love to talk to as many
of you as possible today.
And thank you very
much for coming.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]